[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Dino here.
In this video, we're going
to cover Apigee tracing.
If you haven't got a
working API proxy with API
key verification,
stop here and go back
and view the prior videos now.
In the Apigee UI, select the
proxy we created previously.
This proxy has the
verify API key policy.
Let's use that to
learn about tracing.
Select the Trace tab.
Clicking this green
button tells Apigee
to begin collecting diagnostic
information for each request
it receives for the proxy.
Let's invoke the API again
and we'll see how that works.
I want to make sure I
pass a valid API key.
In the trace window, you
can see, immediately,
I have a trace record
for that request.
Exploring here, I can
see the properties
of the inbound request and also
the results of the verify API
key policy.
I can also see the
outbound request
being sent to the target.
And what's this?
The API key is being
passed to the backend.
That's because the Apigee
Edge proxy is passing
through the request unchanged.
If we want to avoid that,
we can configure the proxy
to modify the request to
remove that query parameter.
Let's do that.
In the preflow, I'll add
an assign message policy.
Assign message is a
multipurpose policy
that can be used to set or
change any part of a message.
Normally, Apigee Edge
propagates an exact copy
of the inbound
message to the target.
But with assign message,
you can make changes--
adding or removing
headers, adding or removing
query parameters.
I'm going to
configure this policy
to remove the query parameter.
Save the proxy.
Flip back to the trace tab.
Start a trace session.
Now invoke the API and
flip back to trace.
And we can see the
assigned message policy is
removing the query parameter.
The proxy is no longer leaking
that API key to the backend.
Great.
Apigee Edge trace gives
near real-time diagnostic
information to API proxy
developers during development.
It will show you up
to 20 transactions.
Now, it's not intended to
deliver a log of transactions.
For that, you can use the
message logging policy.
In this video, we used
the trace facility
and we tried the
assign message policy.
That's just one of the
set of 30-plus policies
that are built into Apigee Edge.
Don't forget, to learn
more, check out the product
documentation and
visit the community
site to explore further.
Be sure to watch the
next video in this series
where we'll cover the
API developer portal.
Until next time,
keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]